secretary ben Carson joint secretary
thank you very much for coming on so as
you well know congresswoman Maloney
called your proposal quote despicable
but it's my understanding that it's
illegal for illegal aliens to be living
in public housing in the first place is
it not that's correct
section 214 of the Housing and Community
Development Act of 1980 specifically
states that the Secretary of HUD is
prohibited from providing housing
assistance to people who are in the
country illegally and what people
sometimes don't understand is that we
have millions of legal Americans in line
waiting for these very scarce resources
what congresswoman and and many others
also don't realize is that we have
provided and mechanism whereby people
who are affected illegals who are
affected and can't find housing can have
delayed action for six months which can
be renewed twice for a total of 18
months which of course is plenty of time
for Congress to do its job so you know
for them to suggest that I should Blake
break the law what is the real
implication that we can just pick and
choose the laws we want to enforce and
embrace of course we feel sympathy for
people of course we don't want anybody
out on the streets but the real thing
that is hurting people is our failure to
address this immigration system the
rules that are drawing people here and
keeping them here and that are so unfair
to American citizens who have been
paying taxes and working here we take in
1.1 million people legally through our
immigration system which is far more
than any other country and let that
system work but it can't work when we
have all these perverse incentives which
are drawing people here so we have
hundreds of thousands of Americans
sleeping outside every night who are
homeless and they're everywhere
absolutely you're telling us that there
are many thousands of illegal aliens
living at public expense in public
housing and Congress has some concern
about what's gonna I mean why would that
be a concern at all foreign citizens
breaking our laws
why wouldn't we spend all of our time
and all of our money all of our energy
worrying about Americans who are living
on the street
well you would you would think we would
do that you know whenever you get on an
airplane and their initial announcements
they say if there's an emergency your
oxygen masks will drop down put yours on
first and then assist your neighbor
obviously we need to take care of our
people doesn't mean that we're not
compassionate people it means that we're
logical people and let's take care of
our people I'm very happy I told the
congresswoman and others if you can find
a way that I can legally do what you
want me to do please tell me what it is
I'm all ears how did she respond change
the subject of course they don't seem to
want to deal with the idea that Congress
is the one who makes the laws instead
they'd rather just say to you why don't
you break the law so that we can feel
good about ourselves why don't they do
their jobs that's what they were elected
to do the American people have a real
choice to make here they need to decide
what kind of people do they want
representing us and it can't just be
somebody whose name you recognize it
needs to be people who are willing to
roll up their sleeves and do the tough
things that need to be done in order for
our country to prosper and when our
country is prosperous I think we can
then turn our attention to some of these
other countries and see what we can do
to help them but we need to get ours in
order first
so congresswoman Maloney is pressuring
you to break the law she's a lawmaker
she could try to change the wall she's
not bothering isn't that prima facie
evidence she's not a serious person I
mean that's foolish well it is very sad
it would be nice if she were the only
one but there are many who feel that way
and I don't think they've really thought
through what's going on they just allow
themselves to be caught up in a moment
and you know they want to be popular and
they're not thinking long-term about
what the impact is of what they're doing
they're not thinking about our children
and our grandchildren and what they will
have to face
it's just what makes me look good today
I've noticed secretary ben Carson thanks
very much for that Thank You Tucker